Let's just go back to our example and see what an amazing thing you've just programmed.
We had a uniform distribution over places.
Each place had a probability of 0.2.
Then you wrote a piece of code that used the measurement to turn this prior
into a posterior, in which the probability of the 2 red cells was
a factor of 3 larger than the posterior of the green cells.
You've done exactly what I gave you intuitively in the beginning as the secret of localization.
You manipulated a probability distribution over places into a new one
by incorporating the measurement.
In fact, let's go back to our code and test in your code whether we get a good result
when we replace our measurement red by green.
Please type green into your measurement variable and rerun your code
to see if you get the correct result.